[Music]
happy New Year we're going to do hatsumo
day which is the first temple visit of
the year you get your fortune and
hopefully we'll get a good one I've
never done this
we've seen them prepare for it it looks
uh interesting
I got a small fortune we got the same
one I didn't Shake mine properly
foreign
[Music]
that's really good it's really sweet
what a scruffy dog oh look you can see
his white
hey we're back today again
you enjoying your brand
[Applause]
no
your turn someone is not a fan here
you're doing great
she loves it
[Music]
are you in a bag of a little bag of
potatoes we're gonna go on a bike ride
Iggy
yeah he loves to be in the back
look who's having a good time
yeah
hi guys it's regular Vlog here
today we're going on a lovely long bike
ride
mama
again loves to be in a backpack I had a
moped in Brighton and we used to go all
the time together
it's good times damn you ride so fast
okay
[Music]
oh my God
probably got engines
time to go out again
[Music]
I don't know
how's it going where's this away with
the Emma today so I'm just chilling at
home been having a very productive day
playing video games but I also want to
show you guys 3D printer I'm so excited
I had one a couple years ago but I
couldn't print anything on it it
wouldn't [__] stick on the thing so
far it's been really good I modeled this
thing
to hopefully fit my lamp mine was just
kind of shitty because it's made for
like any display so I made a custom one
for my own display so hopefully it'll
work I'm gonna print it now and we'll
see I'm very excited someone is very
upset with me
[Music]
are you upset with me
what did I do
she wants to play we play all day the 3D
print is done and it's already up and it
works
perfectly I didn't expect to nail it on
the first try I'm kind of Blown Away you
see there's still a little gap which I
will fix in version two I measured the
wrong side of the cable the slim part
instead of the thick Parts but
everything else I think is great and
even this I'm super happy with so the
one that it came with couldn't do this
so in case I'm shooting a video and I
want extra light sometimes it gets
really dark in it I can do that
oh
it's strawberry season in there they
have a whole Shelf with strawberry
flavored things there it has strawberry
flavored chips but we're going to a
strawberry field it's weird because
strawberries aren't so associated with
summer in Sweden they're here obviously
it's a little different so winter is
strawberry here strawberry day let's go
we found it
so cute
whoa It's so much bigger than I thought
so you get to eat it here it's really
hot in here obviously
[Music]
you gonna try one
oh this looks good so do you
like that it doesn't get fresher than
that
damn
whoa that was massive that's a freak of
nature
you want that one
I found a big boy in Sweden usually eat
it just with candy did I say candy I'm
in sugar
they look so perfect
okay guys are you ready open mouth wow
that's my
laughs
I've been so into 3D printing lately
it's just so satisfying to look at this
one's gonna take me [__] seven hours
but it's supposed to be a cover for my
steam deck and then fit the battery at
the back and I took someone else's uh
crap for the steam neck which works
really well and then I just made the
ugly back thing here hopefully it'll fit
we'll see how it goes
laughs
oh you're in the oh you got it
Mom was about to have her first
dog Pizza hey what a set
all right Mama look as hard as you can
[Music]
yeah you don't [__] with us
right yeah you look hard
how polite again
okay that's plenty
[Music]
they haven't found the horse
come on Japanese people
fix it for you
we're at the Sony flagship store in
Ginza it's really cool
it's uh
we're not getting another dog Mercier oh
he's happy
birthday my wrong oh
it's kind of funny
don't bark at us
[Laughter]
what that's so cool
[Music]
I don't know why but it's really cool
there's Marcia
we should go here it's usually cars
driving here I don't know what's going
on it feels odd I'm walking down the
street
I love the tempura
[Music]
bow
bow damn again
damn in January
I guess some trees bloom earlier
one more can finally walk on a leash
what happened there
[Music]
yay that's a big family
[Applause]
[Music]
what the heck
we made it at last
are you guys excited mom always there's
a big and small section for the dogs
for different sizes someone let us
borrow their code usually have to
register to enter so we'll see how this
goes
a little scared Momo
there's awful we found the introvert at
the park guys I'm too scared to order
the dog
what in the world is happening here
again so here's the final version it's
basically like the same thing but it has
the weight in here I printed in three
parts so this one this one this one and
then they slid together I don't know how
I did it so perfectly it was so
satisfying when I slid it it was like
flick but yeah now I can do that boom
[Music]
they're opening the balls
it's raining so much
[Applause]
that's so nice disaster support
anime Edition
say I'm at a big flea market
I think it happens every year it's
really cool there's a ton of good stuff
but I lost Marcia there she is
found her
we're under attack again
it's huge
no
did I get it I don't see it anymore
you're gonna pay
you don't come to the shellburgs and not
pay the consequences that's right you're
gonna stay in prison dust prison he
didn't he did some damage I give him
that are you on top of that munchie
huh
what are you doing you conquered it
[Music]
we're going to the ramen Museum is that
it wait we've been to the right Museum
today we're going to the Yokohama Ramen
Museum it looks really cool it's like an
indoor area kind of showa area era of
Japan
kinda maybe we'll see I guess I don't
know it looks cool you'll see it in now
there's only really a line
people really want Ramen
at 10 48.
that's crazy
[Music]
wow
that's cool they made it look all old
and stuff
[Music]
no way
I told you it was show era
so they have all like fake shots it's a
camera store
oh what an old Alleyway no way this is
so cool that is so trippy we're like
indoor outdoor
that's so cool
what make it seem like people live here
silver shop
[Music]
so trippy it keeps going it's like Chris
Studio awesome
what
I did not expect this other than just
like a Ramen place
there's even weirder ones upstairs I
can't believe the details
to make everything light I mean this
looks like an old Corridor actually
where does this take us I have no idea
oh careful
yo I caught you almost
[Music]
so these are all the ramen shops
this place is way cooler than I expected
they even have the old school vending
machines
I'm kind of curious to try it
fantastic
oh we came here
it's our bottle opener
it is
ah
okay that's awesome
so all the ramen restaurants here are
old restaurants that have sort of been
really reopened here
so there's one over 100 years old
[Music]
uh ours is from 1954 which is really
cool like a cool way to preserve the the
business
[Music]
looks really good
it tastes really good I'm trying to meet
you saw me but it's really good we got
some
fortunes that we're not gonna be able to
read
pick a good one
it's a good fortune and that's about all
I can read
they have some shops around here we're
gonna check those out
[Music]
foreign
that is
so weird
it's like a gel oh it's Cola it's Cola
flavor I'm so confused by this
I love melon soda flow
I didn't know that was a showa era thing
so this
is a replica oh the very first Ramen
shot
ever made that's so pretty they knew how
to make things look good back in the day
you want some night noodles
they need to bring this back
Ramen on the Wheel
we stumble upon the Pokemon Center so I
guess we should check it out
we're eating so many snacks today but I
keep seeing snacks everywhere and I'm
like oh I want that
that looks good
what's the name of this one
okay so they have all these cute ones
and then they have this atrocity I've
seen this on photos man I am not up to
date with the latest Pokemon
Mars is falling in love in a new Pokemon
beautiful
bring some sort of game story I don't
know what it is
there's so many cool figurines but as an
epic minimalist I have to show restraint
they have so many bizarre board games
wrestling simulator
Spaceballs I feel like it could be a
good video
damn
they have so many like old games too I
know they are everywhere but I've never
been into one yet oh they have the
actual one no way
you never use the scratchy thing it's no
point what on Earth hell yeah
forever with you tennis game
I love it I want everything
I found the culture aisle
2000 for that card
crazy damn crazy prices
this shop is just draining me there's so
much cool stuff but I'm like no
[Music]
foreign
colors of wood I really like the light
one looks cool what's up gamers
I'm very excited because I got tickets
to go to a sumo wrestling match
apparently they're quite hard to come by
I was gifted them to me I'm excited oh
this is good
[Music]
[Applause]
Merry Christmas
[Music]
oh
damn
oh get him oh
appearance
[Applause]
the big boys
[Music]
hell yeah that's my favorite right there
[Applause]
holy [__]
man
whoa
guy on the left is clown guy
's on the right whoa
that was close
[Music]
[Applause]
that was close
oh
rest in peace clone game
[Music]
we're entering the last couple matches
it's more intense now they always psych
each other out in the beginning
watch it's gonna happen there we go both
hands down no what
whoa got him yeah
[Laughter]
good psych good site he psyched himself
out
okay
one hand down
[Music]
all right
my hands needs to touch for both players
and then the game starts
here we go
[Applause]
ubm so hard there he goes
get that cash
[Applause]
[Music]
you see their disappointment in their
face says there's so much preparation
for these matches I don't know if I
showed but we're sitting in these like
Square inbox areas it's really cool it's
the last match of Joey and Connor
I don't think they're gonna make it
[Applause]
sponsor time
good brands I think the guy on the left
got it
yeah here we go
oh little frog jump there that was
interesting yeah
oh
damn they're slapping whoa
yeah
[Applause]
damn that's he got the bag dude
get that money what an experience
that was amazing